estaba escalando solo, sin soga.
Es un tipo de escalada que se llama "libre en solitario".
Fue la culminación del sueño de casi una década,
y en el vídeo me encuentro a más de 762 m de altura.
¿Parece aterrador? Lo es.
Por eso pasé tantos años soñando con escalar El Cap
sin atreverme a hacerlo.
Pero el día en que se hizo esa filmación,
no sentí miedo en absoluto.
Fue tan cómodo y natural como caminar por el parque,
que es lo que hacía la mayoría en Yosemite aquel día.
Hoy quiero contarles cómo hice para sentirme tan seguro
y superar el miedo.
Les contaré brevemente cómo empecé a escalar,
y luego relataré mis dos escaladas en solitario más importantes.
Logré hacer las dos, por eso puedo contarlo hoy.
(Risas)
Pero la primera escalada no me conformó,
en tanto que la segunda, el ascenso a El Cap, fue el mejor día de mi vida.
Cuando les cuente de ambas escaladas, verán cómo fui superando el miedo.
A los 10 años, comencé a escalar en un gimnasio,
es decir que mi vida gira en torno a la escalada desde hace más de 20 años.
Tras una década de práctica en ámbitos cerrados,
empecé a hacerlo al aire libre y de a poco incursioné en la escalada libre.
Con el tiempo me fui afianzando
y de a poco fui escalando paredes más grandes y difíciles.
Hubo muchos montañistas de escalada libre que me inspiraron en mis comienzos.
Para 2008, ya había repetido casi todas sus escaladas libres en Yosemite
y empecé a considerar la idea de hacer nuevas incursiones.
La primera y obvia elección fue Half Dome,
una icónica pared de 610 m que domina el extremo este del valle.
El problema, y también el atractivo,
eran sus grandes dimensiones.
No sabía cómo prepararme para una posible escalada libre.
Entonces decidí ignorar los preparativos, escalar y lanzarme a la aventura.
Pensé que estaría a la altura de las circunstancias,
pero, como era de esperar, no fue la mejor estrategia.
Al menos ascendí con un amigo dos días antes, sujeto a una cuerda,
para asegurarme de conocer el camino
y poner a prueba mi físico.
Pero cuando a los dos días regresé sin compañía,
decidí que no lo haría por ese itinerario.
Sabía de un desvío de unos 90 m
que evitaba pasar una parte muy difícil de la escalada.
De pronto decidí evitar esa parte y tomar el desvío,
a pesar de que nunca lo había escalado.
Pero enseguida empecé a dudar.
Imagínense solos en el centro exacto de una pared de 610 m
preguntándose si se han perdido.
(Risas)
Por suerte, yo estaba en el camino correcto,
hice el desvío y retomé el trayecto.
Estaba un poco alterado, bastante alterado,
pero traté de mantener la calma
porque sabía que la parte más difícil era más arriba.
Necesitaba mantener la calma.
Era una bella mañana de septiembre
y, al ascender, se oía a los turistas que hablaban y reían en la cima.
Habían llegado por atrás, por el sendero tradicional,
que era como yo pensaba descender.
Pero entre la cima y yo había una enorme pared de granito.
No tenía grietas ni bordes donde aferrarme,
tan solo pequeñas salientes en una pared casi vertical.
Mi vida dependía de la fricción entre el calzado y el granito liso.
Ascendí balanceándome con cuidado,
inclinando mi peso de un lado a otro entre las pequeñas salientes,
hasta que llegué a un apoyo no del todo confiable.
Dos días antes, sujeto a la cuerda, habría puesto el pie.
Ahora, ese apoyo parecía muy pequeño y resbaladizo.
No sabía si al apoyar el pie permanecería en el lugar.
Pensé en poner el pie más al costado, pero parecía peor.
Cambié de pie y probé más afuera,
pero parecía peor aún.
Empecé a entrar en pánico.
Oía la risa de la gente más arriba, en la cima.
Quería estar en cualquier sitio menos ahí.
Mi cabeza pensaba a toda velocidad.
Sabía qué debía hacer, pero tenía demasiado miedo.
Solo tenía que apoyar el pie derecho.
Y así, en lo que pareció una eternidad, decidí hacer lo que debía
y apoyé el pie derecho.
No me resbalé, y no perdí la vida,
y ese movimiento marcó el final de la parte más difícil.
Y de allí fui hacia a la cima.
Cuando alguien hace cima en Half Dome,
en general llega con cuerdas y el equipo de montaña,
y los turistas asombrados se agolpan para sacar fotos.
Esta vez me asomé al borde con el torso desnudo, agitado.
Estaba acelerado, pero nadie me dirigió la mirada.
(Risas)
Parecía un turista perdido, demasiado cerca del precipicio.
La gente hablaba por teléfono y comía.
Era como estar en un centro comercial.
(Risas)
Me quité el calzado, empecé a bajar a pie por el sendero,
y allí fue donde la gente me abordó:
"¿Caminas descalzo? Eso es para expertos".
(Risas)
No me detuve a explicar...
Esa noche escribí en mi diario que había ascendido el Half Dome,
pero también puse una carita enojada con el comentario: "¿Podría ser mejor?".
Había logrado el ascenso
y fue considerado un hito del montañismo.
Al tiempo, unos amigos hicieron una película.
Pero yo no estaba conforme.
No me gustó mi desempeño,
porque sabía que la había hecho fácil.
No quería ser un escalador de suerte, sino de excelencia.
Me alejé de la disciplina durante un año,
pues no quería acostumbrarme a depender de la suerte.
Si bien no estaba practicando,
ya empezaba a pensar en El Cap.
Siempre lo consideré como la joya de las escaladas libres.
Es la pared más impresionante del mundo.
Durante los siete años siguientes,
pensé: "Este año ascenderé El Cap".
Y luego iba a Yosemite, miraba la pared, y pensaba:
"De ninguna manera".
(Risas)
Es demasiado grande, y da terror.
Pero de a poco fui aceptando que quería asumir el desafío de El Cap.
Era el símbolo de la máxima destreza,
pero quería que fuera distinto.
No quería atajos fáciles ni llegar a duras penas.
Esta vez quería hacerlo bien.
Lo que intimida de El Cap es el tamaño de la pared.
Los escaladores suelen tardar 3 a 5 días
en ascender el granito vertical de 914 m.
La idea de escalar una pared de ese tamaño
sin nada más que calzado y un bolsito de tiza, parecía imposible.
Un ascenso de 914 m supone miles de movimientos de manos y pies,
que es un montón para recordar.
Muchos movimientos los conocía por repetición.
Había escalado El Cap unas 50 veces durante una década con una soga.
Esta foto muestra mi método preferido para ensayar los movimientos.
Allí estoy en la cima,
a punto de descender en rapel con una cuerda de más de 300 m
a modo de práctica.
Cuando encontraba secuencias que parecían seguras y repetibles,
las memorizaba con tal precisión
que no dejaban margen para el error.
No quería dudar del camino a tomar ni de los apoyos que debía usar.
Quería que todo me surgiera de manera automática.
Escalar con cuerda es un esfuerzo mayormente físico.
Hay que tener la fuerza para aferrarse y hacer movimientos para subir.
Pero la escalada libre es más mental.
El esfuerzo físico es básicamente el mismo;
el cuerpo debe escalar la misma pared.
Pero mantener la calma y hacer las cosas bien,
sabiendo que un error puede significar la muerte,
requiere de un temple especial.
(Risas)
No se supone que cause gracia, pero si es así, está bien.
Trabajé para cultivar ese temple mediante la visualización,
que básicamente consiste en imaginar la experiencia completa de la escalada.
En parte, me ayudaba a recordar los sitios de apoyo,
pero la visualización era, en esencia, sentir la textura
de cada punto de apoyo
e imaginar la sensación de estirar la pierna y poner el pie en esta posición.
Me imaginaba una coreografía en altura.
El peor tramo de la ruta era el llamado "problema del 'boulder'".
Estaba a unos 610 m de altura
y requería los movimientos más difíciles del trayecto:
estirarse entre agarres poco seguros y apoyos pequeños y resbaladizos.
Por "agarre poco seguro" me refiero a esto:
un borde hacia abajo, más estrecho que el ancho de un lápiz,
donde debía presionar hacia arriba con el pulgar.
Pero eso no era lo peor.
Lo peor terminaba con una patada de karate
con el pie izquierdo para llegar a un rincón adyacente,
una maniobra de gran precisión y flexibilidad
que practiqué con una rutina de elongación todas las noches durante un año
para asegurarme de poder llegar cómodamente con la pierna.
Durante esa práctica,
me proyectaba en el aspecto emocional de una potencial escalada libre.
Básicamente, ¿y si al llegar me invadía el temor,
o el cansancio?
¿Y si no lograba dar esa patada?
Debía prever todas las posibilidades mientras estaba en tierra segura
para que, al momento de hacer los movimientos sin la soga,
no hubiera espacio para dudas.
La duda antecede al miedo,
y sabía que no podría disfrutar del momento perfecto si tenía miedo.
Tenía que prever y ensayar lo necesario como para disipar cualquier duda.
Pero también tenía que visualizar cómo me sentiría si no lo lograba.
¿Qué pasaría si, después de tanto trabajo, temía intentarlo?
¿Y si estuviera perdiendo el tiempo
y nunca me iba a sentir seguro en una posición tan expuesta?
No había respuestas fáciles,
pero El Cap valía la pena, y quise hacer el intento para averiguarlo.
Algunos de mis preparativos fueron más triviales.
En esta foto aparece mi amigo Conrad Anker
escalando El Cap con una mochila vacía.
Subimos juntos hasta una grieta justo en el medio de la pared.
Estaba llena de piedras sueltas
que tornaban esa parte difícil y potencialmente peligrosa,
porque cualquier paso mal dado podía hacer caer una roca
y matar a un escalador o senderista.
Entonces quitamos las rocas, las pusimos en la mochila
y descendimos.
Imaginen por un segundo lo ridículo que resulta
escalar 450 m por una pared para llenar una mochila con piedras.
(Risas)
No es fácil andar cargando una mochila con piedras;
imaginen en la pared de un acantilado.
Parecía ilógico, pero había que hacerlo.
Si alguna vez iba a escalar sin cuerda, necesitaba que todo estuviera perfecto.
Luego de dos temporadas de práctica para un posible ascenso a El Cap,
por fin terminé con mi entrenamiento.
Conocía cada agarre y cada apoyo en el trayecto,
y sabía exactamente qué hacer.
En definitiva, estaba listo.
Era hora de enfrentar a El Cap.
El 3 de junio de 2017,
me levanté temprano, desayuné como de costumbre mi muesli con frutas
y fui al pie del paredón antes del amanecer.
Miré hacia arriba, y me sentí seguro.
Cuando empecé a escalar, me sentí aún mejor.
A los 150 m, llegué a un bloque
muy parecido al que me había dado tanto trabajo en el Half Dome,
pero esta vez era diferente.
Había explorado cientos de metros de pared a cada lado de la ruta.
Sabía exactamente qué hacer, y de qué manera.
No tuve dudas. Simplemente, seguí escalando.
Aun las partes más difíciles y cansadoras me resultaron fáciles.
Estaba ejecutando mi rutina a la perfección.
Justo antes del peor tramo descansé un momento,
y luego lo escalé como lo había hecho tantas veces con la cuerda.
Estiré la pierna izquierda sin dudar,
y supe que lo había logrado.
Escalar Half Dome había sido un gran objetivo, y lo conseguí,
pero no logré lo que realmente quería.
No alcancé la máxima destreza.
Tenía dudas y miedos, y no era la experiencia que quería.
Pero El Cap fue distinto.
Faltando 182 m, sentí que la montaña me ofrecía la vuelta ganadora.
Escalé con precisión
y disfruté oyendo los pájaros que se lanzaban en picada.
Era como una celebración.
Y llegué a la cima
luego de 3 horas y 56 minutos maravillosos de escalada.
Fue lo que esperaba, y sentí que alcancé la máxima destreza.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)